JUSTIN BOYAN: Great.
Hey, everybody, how you doing?
Everybody having fun?
We're having fun.
I'm Justin Boyan.
I'm a product manager in the
Google Cambridge, Mass office.
JOSH AIN: And I'm Josh Ain.
I'm a software engineer,
also in the
Google Cambridge office.
JUSTIN BOYAN: And we are going
to do a deep dive into four
tools that Google is providing
to help webmasters and people
who author HTML provide a
structured view of their data
to Google and other
search engines.
So before we get started, how
many of you actually have a
website or work for an
organization that has a website?
Who the heck doesn't
have a website?
How many of you have
written HTML for
that website or others?
Every kid these days knows
how to write HTML.
Now, how many of you have
included structured
markup in that HTML?
Microformats, microdata,
RDFa, OGP?
About half.
Perfect.
So that's what we're seeing
on the web, as well.
And this talk we're going to
cover two kinds of tools.
Tools for those of you who have
already put structured
markup into your HTML, and those
of you who haven't yet
and need a little boost
getting started.
So four tools we're going
to demo are--
for those of you who already
have structured markup, the
Structured Data Testing Tool,
the Structured Data Dashboard.
And then for those of you who
are just getting started with
providing structured data on
your websites, the Data
Highlighter tool, which is
launched yesterday with seven
additional data types, and the
Structured Data Markup Helper,
an all new tool that
launched yesterday.
So just if you missed the last
session, I'm going to briefly
recap why are you interested
in providing a structured
semantic view of your
data to Google?
And it's because Google is going
well beyond the plain
vanilla 10 blue links in
response to search.
We want to provide answers,
anticipation, and enhanced
presentation of the results,
which we can do if we
understand the structure of the
data on your web pages.
So for starters, there
are rich snippets.
If you provide structured
information about your event
listings or your product
listings, your recipes, the
review content on your sites,
and other similar data
formats, we can highlight your
search results with enhanced
treatment that helps
users find what
they're looking for quicker.
For recipes, we go a bit further
and actually provide
search tools that allow users to
filter the results based on
the structured content
in your pages.
So certainly, if you're
searching for chocolate chip
cookie recipe, you want to
exclude the recipes with
pecans and walnuts because
that's an atrocity.
And we provide you the ability
to do that powered by
structured markup
in web pages.
We are integrating with the
Knowledge Graph, so if you
provide reviews of movies, say,
when a user searches for
a movie we can highlight that
data right in front and center
in the knowledge graph
presentation for that movie.
And for events, we've got
a lot of treatments.
So launching just a couple
days ago, is this events
carousel, we call it.
Somebody comes in searching
for events in a city--
I believe this was launched
US only--
we feature a nice carousel
of the most popular
events in that city.
We also, as Jason showed last
session, we'll blend in events
from web data into searches
for a band or for a venue.
And these event data items are
also showing up in mobile
interfaces like Google Now.
So to make your data eligible
to participate in all these
cool enhanced search treatments,
you need us to
understand the structure
of the data.
And there are many ways
of doing that.
Our number one recommendation
is to use microdata with
schema.org vocabulary.
What do you think?
Is that easy enough?
JOSH AIN: Looks difficult
to me, Justin.
JUSTIN BOYAN: Yeah, it's not
that bad, but we do recognize
there are many competing
formats.
There are microformats,
microdata, RDFa, OGP, et
cetera, and it can be confusing
for webmasters to
know exactly what they're
supposed to do and what
they're supposed to provide.
So that's where our team is
working hard to try to make
things easier.
So let's get into the demos.
We'll start with the two tools
that help you check existing
markup that you've already
applied to web pages.
The structured data testing
tool, this is the situation
where you have a single web
page, you want to check if
you've applied markup
the right way.
It's a validation tool.
Anybody can go use this tool.
You don't even need
to be logged in.
You go to the Webmaster Tools
Rich Snippets site, paste in
the URL or actually, the source
HTML of your page, and
Google will show you what we
understand of the structured
data on that page.
So to demonstrate this tool I
have brought on the pretend
webmaster for a local museum,
the San Francisco Museum of
Modern Art.
We don't actually have a
preexisting relationship with
SFMOMA, but just for demo
purposes, Josh will pretend to
be the SFMOMA webmaster.
JOSH AIN: One second.
So hello.
As you can clearly see by my
hat, I'm the webmaster of the
San Francisco Museum
of Modern Art.
Just kidding.
I don't actually have any
knowledge of whether the
webmaster of San Francisco
Museum of Modern Art wears a
hat like this or does any of the
other things I'm going to
do, but for the purpose of
motivating this example I'm
talking about the motivations
of this webmaster.
So I have events going on at
the San Francisco Museum of
Modern Art and I would like to
make sure that as many people
as possible know about these
upcoming events.
If you're staying in town next
week after Google I/O or if
you live here, we've got a
great event going on, the
Agent Ruby files.
This is based on an AI
art and exploration
project that goes on.
And I think it's really
interesting.
So if you're here, you
should check it out.
I want to make sure everybody
knows about that, and I want
Google to share details
about this event.
JUSTIN BOYAN: But we're
not showing rich
snippets for that event.
JOSH AIN: Right, we're not
showing rich snippets right
now, I know that.
And I want to figure out why.
So I've already added
structured
markup to this page.
And I'm going to take the URL
of this event and go over to
the Google Structured Data
Testing tool and
paste in this URL.
I could also paste in
HTML if I hadn't
published the URL yet.
And I'll say Preview.
So here, I see the search
treatment which I already know
I'm getting for the event.
And it's just a normal
search result.
There's nothing event-specific
about it.
If I scroll down further, I can
see that Google does pick
up the structured data that I've
added to the site, so why
isn't my event showing up?
JUSTIN BOYAN: Well, you've got
your microformats there.
You've shown the start date and
summary and description of
the event, but you haven't given
us a location we can
understand.
JOSH AIN: Ah, so here I can
learn that I need to add the
location and then maybe I
can get event treatment.
Let's try that out.
JUSTIN BOYAN: So if the real
webmaster of SFMOMA were to go
back and fix up the microformat
to connect in the
location properly, then
re-previewing in the
Structured Data Testing
tool would show that--
there you go-- the rich snippet
line, which shows
clearly the date and location
of that event.
And also, seeing that preview in
the rich snippet will also
indicate that Google has
understood the data in a way
that's usable and makes the
event eligible for all the
other search presentations
of events.
JOSH AIN: There we go.
That's much better.
That's exactly what I want.
Thanks.
JUSTIN BOYAN: We'll move on to
the Structured Data Dashboard.
So this goes beyond single
page validation.
Here again, you are a webmaster
who has already
applied markup to your site,
perhaps over a variety of
different pages and a variety
of different types.
And you would like to understand
holistically
whether Google is picking
up your data correctly.
So log into Webmaster Tools,
which you need
to be verified for.
And go to the Structured
Data Dashboard.
To demonstrate that, I'll bring
back my SFMOMA webmaster.
JOSH AIN: Hello, I'm still the
webmaster at San Francisco
Museum of Modern Art.
And I'm going to go into my
Structured Data Dashboard.
Here it is.
I'm already a verified
webmaster
of my site, of course.
And I can see Google's
understanding of the
structured data on my
site over time.
So I haven't made any
significant changes to my
structured data recently, and
that's why these lines are
pretty flat.
But if I just added a lot of
structured data, you could see
when Google re-crawls the site
and when Google picks it up.
I can also see what
Google knows.
Google knows about 23 and 1/2
thousand items split over 15
and 1/2 thousand pages.
And they're split into two
different types of structured
data, hCards, or contact
information, and
hCalendars, or events.
And I've got 9,000 events.
If I want more details on
Google's understanding, I can
just drill in here and see a
bunch of different example
pages that have hCalendars
and Google's
interpretation of them.
Now, to go back to the example
we were looking at, I know
that the URL of the Agent Ruby
files ends in 2295, because as
a good webmaster,
I've memorized
every URL on my website.
And so I have the Agent
Ruby files.
I can see that that's
the same page we
were looking at earlier.
And when I click on it, we'll
bring up the details.
Here they are.
We'll bring up the details of
Google's understanding.
So, similar to what I saw
earlier in the testing tool,
only now I can easily see it on
lots of different pages one
after another.
JUSTIN BOYAN: So it's
essentially like applying the
Structured Data Testing tool
to your whole site
simultaneously and getting
an overview.
And right now the Dashboard
team is hard at work
integrating error information in
a really nice way into that
Dashboard display.
You'll be seeing that roll out
early this summer, I hope,
although we don't like to
pre-announce things.
But here's a mock of what
it's going to look like.
So it features quite clearly
along the top row what
different classes of errors
we've observed in your
structured data markup, and then
we surface those pages
with errors on them
to the top.
So the idea is to really help
webmasters debug problems in
their markup so that Google
can understand it clearly.
So that concludes the first
half of tools that we're
providing to people who
are already using
markup on their pages.
Now, let's shift gears to those
of you who don't yet
have markup and aren't yet
explaining your structured
data to Google.
How do you get Google--
how do you start participating
in all the enhanced features
that structured data enables?
We're going to show two
fancy and slick tools.
The first is Data Highlighter.
Data Highlighter launched
in December for events.
As of yesterday, it is now
available for seven additional
types of data, almost all of the
rich snippet data formats
that Google supports.
Data Highlighter is a tool
that's, like the Dashboard,
built into Webmaster Tools,
and allows you, without
actually changing the HTML of
your pages at all, to get a
taste of what structured markup
could do for you.
So how can Google get an
understanding of your
structured data without you
editing your HTML at all?
It works by machine learning
and a point and click UI.
So you actually start with a
sample page that contains the
kind of data you would like
Google to understand.
You apply a point and click
tagging operation to label the
key data fields on
those pages.
And then Google extrapolates the
pattern of the tags that
you've applied to other similar
pages on your website.
So we'll have Josh demonstrate
how the Data
Highlighter tool works.
But let's bring in a different
webmaster.
I'd like to call up the
webmaster of the 826 Valencia
Pirate Supply Store.
JOSH AIN: Hold on.
Let me get him.
Arr.
I'm the webmaster of 826
Valencia, San Francisco's only
independent pirate
supply store.
And so I hope if you have any
pirate supply needs while
you're in town, you
know where to go.
As an independent--
now, again, I'm not really
the webmaster.
This is just for example,
explaining how somebody might
use this tool.
So I'm a busy shop owner.
I don't have a lot of time
to go and add every
feature to my website.
What I care about is making
sure people know about my
store, know what's in stock,
and know about
my important events.
So Talk Like a Pirate Day is
coming right up and people
need their pirate
gear for that.
I want to make sure that they
can find all of my products on
Google when I do that.
So what I'm going to do is I'm
going to take my URL--
a URL for one of my favorite
products, the Hook--
copy it, and go into Webmaster
Tools Data Highlighter.
So that's just under
Optimization.
And I'm a verified webmaster,
of course.
But I just don't have time
to add all of the
markup to my page.
I'm going to train Google
how to fetch the data.
So I'm going to paste the URL
in for my hook and choose a
type of data I want
to highlight.
So this is a product.
I want to tell people
how to buy it.
And I want to tag this page
and others like it.
I just want to tag all the
product pages on my site.
So let's get started.
JUSTIN BOYAN: So once you've
told us about that first
sample URL, we're going to
load the page in and
instrument it for this point and
click tagging operation.
JOSH AIN: So I can see, here
on the right are the fields
that Google's interested
in about a product.
So a name, an image,
price information.
And here's my web page, along
with some guidance on what I
have to do to share this data.
So I'm going to just highlight
this hook,
the name of my product.
And then I get this interface
that lets me tell Google what
this data means.
So this is the name
of my product.
Down here we have a price.
And here's an image
for my hook.
And I think that's enough
information.
There's other fields, but I
don't have ratings or reviews
on my site, so I think
that's enough.
I'll click Done.
What's this, Justin?
JUSTIN BOYAN: At this point,
we're looking at the structure
of your website and finding a
URL pattern that seems to
contain similarly formatted
web pages.
And so in this case, we're
guessing that the slash store
slash product slash star might
be the set of pages that
you're interested in
sharing with us.
JOSH AIN: So as any good
webmaster or shop owner knows,
I know all the URLs on my
website, and I know that all
of my products fall under
that pattern, so it
looks great to me.
I'm going to create a page
set and keep going.
JUSTIN BOYAN: Now, at this
point, we're going to suggest
a few more examples of pages
from within that URL pattern
and get him to confirm
that we've
understood them correctly.
We'll try and look for pages
that maybe don't fit the
pattern, are formatted
a little differently.
JOSH AIN: So here I can see the
powder horn, which is $38.
And the data that I expect is
showing up here on the right,
indicating Google's
understanding.
Looks good to me.
I'll click Next.
The seahose.
Also looks like Google
understands what that means.
I'll click Next.
Holiday card bundle.
Looks good to me.
And individual signs.
Yep, just $4.
So I guess I'm done with
five examples.
JUSTIN BOYAN: It doesn't always
go that smoothly, but
you're training a pattern
recognition system.
So if your site has more
variability than this one, you
may have to clear some of our
incorrectly guessed tags and
correctly reapply those tags.
But generally, after five or
sometimes 10 pages, we will
have understood your pattern and
you can click through to
the next phase.
JOSH AIN: Great.
I'll click Done and
keep going.
JUSTIN BOYAN: So this
is the final review.
We provide a wider sample of
pages that you can quickly
skim through, just to check.
Again, sanity check that we're
pulling the right information
from the set of pages
you gave us.
JOSH AIN: So, I see.
I can just review all
of these pages.
And all of these look like the
products I have in stock.
It doesn't look like Google
has made any mistakes.
So I'm done.
JUSTIN BOYAN: Yeah,
hit Publish.
And that will actually install
the pattern recognition into
the Google crawling algorithms,
so that in the
future as we gather updated
information from your site we
will interpret that structured
data as if you had applied
markup to the pages directly.
JOSH AIN: But when do
I get snippets?
I want to make sure that I
have them for Talk Like a
Pirate Day.
JUSTIN BOYAN: Well, as we
re-crawl your site, those
snippets will start appearing.
I think talk like a
Pirate Day is--
when?
JOSH AIN: September.
JUSTIN BOYAN: Yeah,
you'll be fine.
JOSH AIN: Great.
Thanks a lot, Justin.
JUSTIN BOYAN: So again, Data
Highlighter, as of yesterday,
supports eight types of data.
That's in addition to events,
articles, local businesses,
movies and movie reviews,
products, as you just saw,
restaurants, software
applications, and TV episodes.
So if your website has any of
those kinds of data on it, you
can get a quick jump into the
world of structured data by
applying Data Highlighter,
as you just saw.
You don't even need to modify
your actual website.
Of course, there's a downside
to using Data Highlighter,
which is only Google will have
that pattern recognition
installed after you
do this process.
So it will make your snippets
available on Google, but it's
not nicely sharing that data
with the rest of the open web.
And we're sensitive to that.
We recommend that you do
transition to implementing
full markup on your
site when you can.
But having said that, it is a
great and easy way to get
started exploring what markup
will do for your site.
When you are ready to transition
to markup, we are
announcing as of today a new
tool, Structured Data Markup
Helper, which is also available
for all those same
data types you just saw
in Data Highlighter.
You again, apply the same
point and click tagging
operation to a sample web
page on your site.
And this time, instead of trying
to fancily learn the
pattern of your whole site
what we're going to do is
recommend microdata and
schema.org markup that you can
then copy into your
HTML source.
So to demonstrate how Structured
Data Markup Helper
works, I'd like to send away
the pirate and bring on the
web master-- the pretend
webmaster of the Computer
History Museum down
in Mountain View.
JOSH AIN: Hello, everybody.
As you can clearly see by my
Nintendo Entertainment System
hat, I'm the webmaster of the
Computer History Museum.
I'm a big aficionado of
all things computer.
I'm not actually
the webmaster.
I'm not sure that he has this
hat, but I hope he does.
Regardless, I'm very excited
about structured markup.
I have events on my site.
I want to share them
with the world.
But there's a lot going on in
the Computer History Museum,
and I haven't had time to
add the markup yet.
And I'm really excited for
Google to help me do that.
Now, I know a lot about the
history of computers and I see
where we're going.
And I see structured markup as
the future of computing on the
web, and I want the Computer
History Museum to be part of
that, for sure.
So to get started, I'm going
to take this URL of my
upcoming events, copy
it, and go into the
Structured Markup Helper.
So here in the Structured Data
Markup Helper I'll paste in my
URL into this field.
I could also paste in HTML if
was building a new site and
hadn't put it online yet.
And then choose what type
of data I want to tag.
So here I want to tag events.
Once I'm done with that, I'll
go ahead and start tagging.
JUSTIN BOYAN: We'll instrument
the page for point and click
tagging, just like we did
in Data Highlighter.
JOSH AIN: So here we go.
That's the same page that
we were just looking at.
And I've got my fields for
events, the fields that
Google's interested
in for an event.
So I'll go ahead and highlight
my first event.
There's the name.
There's the date.
Here's an image to go
with the event.
And I think that's enough.
JUSTIN BOYAN: Yeah, well,
you've got multiple
events on that page.
I'm afraid you're going to
have to keep on tagging.
JOSH AIN: OK.
We'll do my second one.
And oh, what just happened
there, Justin?
JUSTIN BOYAN: A little
bit of magic.
When we recognize there's a
repeated structure of HTML on
your page, we'll go ahead and
automatically suggest the rest
of the tags on that page, so you
don't need to do them all
one by one.
JOSH AIN: So that looks right.
Looking at the tags, it looks
like the whole page is filled
in with all of my events.
And even notice that the first
two events have images but
subsequent events did not.
And it was OK with that.
Looking at the right I can
review my data, and all of my
events are there.
So I guess I'm done.
JUSTIN BOYAN: Go ahead
in create HTML.
And here's where we'll show you
sample markup that you can
go ahead and apply
to your site.
So you'll see highlighted in
yellow on the right-hand side
all our recommended additions.
So scrolling down there you see
we have suggested an item
type of schema.org/event and
several item props for the
date and name and image
on those events.
JOSH AIN: So it looks great.
JUSTIN BOYAN: You can also see
we've shown you how to
normalize the date into the
recommended schema.org ISO
8601 format.
JOSH AIN: That's great.
And I can just take these new
sections and add them to my
templating system, and then
I'll have markup.
JUSTIN BOYAN: Right on.
JOSH AIN: Now, is this
everything that I need, then?
I'm done?
JUSTIN BOYAN: Well, let me tell
you about an unfortunate
experience that my friend at
the San Francisco Museum of
Modern Art had.
JOSH AIN: Ohm I know him well.
He's a good guy.
JUSTIN BOYAN: Yeah, well,
he didn't connect up the
locations to his events
properly.
I think you better go back
and add location.
JOSH AIN: Let's see if
we can fix that.
So I've got the location up
here, the Computer History
Museum,
JUSTIN BOYAN: Oh, god,
that's an image.
How's going to work?
JOSH AIN: So I'll tag that
as the location name.
JUSTIN BOYAN: Yes, in this
case, the alt text on the
image, as frequently is the
case, corresponds to the
semantic content of what
that image represents.
So we've just pulled
the alt text in.
We also noticed that it was
structurally outside the scope
of the events on the page, and
so we've distributed that
location down and put it
in each of the events.
JOSH AIN: Oh, good, yeah.
It's in each of my events
rather than
just the first event.
Perfect.
JUSTIN BOYAN: Right.
JOSH AIN: Let's see the
HTML that creates.
JUSTIN BOYAN: Right.
So here it's become a little bit
more complicated because
of the non-hierarchical nature,
the non self-contained
nature of the events.
So the recommended markup
uses a feature of
microdata called itemref.
So it shows you how
to do that.
Little more complicated, but
still gives you something to
work from as you implement
markup on your site.
JOSH AIN: Looks great to me.
Thanks, Justin.
JUSTIN BOYAN: Yes.
That is the Structured
Data Markup Helper.
It is available to any logged
in Google user.
You do not need to
be a webmaster
to use Markup Helper.
It, like I said before, is
available for the same eight
data types the Data
Highlighter is.
So there they are
on the screen.
In addition, we are supporting
the smart email schemas that
were announced yesterday
and will be discussed
further this afternoon.
So if you want to annotate an
HTML email with information
about a flight reservation or
a hotel reservation, things
like that, this tool will
help you add markup to
that email as well.
And that will output in JSON-LD
format, as well as microdata.
JOSH AIN: So that's
very exciting.
I believe there are sessions at
2:15, or somewhere around
then this afternoon.
You should definitely check
it out, as well.
JUSTIN BOYAN: So that basically
concludes our four demos.
Again, in summary, we've got
two tools that help you
validate markup that you've
already applied to your site.
We've got Data Highlighter that
lets you test the waters
of structured markup by very
quickly, without even having
the access or the time to modify
your website, show
Google how to understand it.
And when you are ready to start
adding markup at first,
there's the new Markup Helper.
And that's all we've got.
We would be very happy
to take questions.
JOSH AIN: And we also
have some shirts for
you on the way out.
Would you like to show them
the shirts, Justin?
JUSTIN BOYAN: Yes, without--
JOSH AIN: It's this
flannel shirt.
No, just kidding.
Nice flannel shirts.
JUSTIN BOYAN: Don't you worry
about a schema.org/Thing.
JOSH AIN: So those are on the
way out, if you're interested.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Let's say I work for a large
retailer that has hundreds of
thousands of products
on the web.
Can you help me give a business
case to my bosses to
tell them, we really need
to open this up.
Obviously, it's creating a new
available marketplace of
getting just the information
out there for all people to
consume that data is one
of the big reasons.
Are there other ways that you
would recommend doing that?
JOSH AIN: So just repeat the
question, I think what I heard
was, working for a big retailer
with lots of products.
How do you make the business
case for the value of adding
this markup and what
it gets you.
Is that right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
JUSTIN BOYAN: The basic sell
is enhanced presentation in
search results.
So if you're a retailer and
when your organic search
results don't show that
product and price rich
snippet, then you're missing
out on the chance to really
show people my product's
in stock.
This is the cost
of my product.
It's really for sale and it's
got a four star review.
So the intent is to make the
more relevant data available
to users so the people who come
to your site are knowing
what they're getting.
AUDIENCE: So it's
one less click.
So they don't have to click
through to see that same
information.
JOSH AIN: They don't have to
click through, but also,
you're giving them a reason to
click through by telling them
it's in stock and providing
the other important
information, the information
that we find people are most
likely to look for to entice
them to click on your links
and come to your site.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Just a quick question about how
you handling JavaScript.
JOSH AIN: OK.
Yeah, we do our best.
So are you talking about in
Data Highlighter or??
AUDIENCE: Yeah, because a lot of
data and especially images
are provided dynamically
through JavaScript.
JUSTIN BOYAN: Yeah, we do our
best to actually execute the
JavaScript and provide you
access to the rendered version
of the page, post JavaScript.
JOSH AIN: At a technical level,
we're not showing you
the raw HTML.
We are rendering the page
in a browser and then
showing that to you.
So it doesn't work 100% of the
time, but most of the time if
you have JavaScript that's
executing on load to show
images, et cetera, those will
show up in the version that we
display in Data Highlighter
and Markup Helper.
AUDIENCE: And if we have
navigation through images, is
that something you would--
I mean, you don't actually
follow navigation, do you?
JUSTIN BOYAN: We don't follow
navigation, that's right.
JOSH AIN: Right.
So we do allow you to tag a
link, if that's an important
piece of information.
But we're not navigating
the site.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I'm [INAUDIBLE].
And my question is, with
relation to the last example,
so you applied the structured
markup to a list of events.
I wanted to know one, what is
the best practice there versus
putting the markup
on your list page
versus the detail page?
And in the search results,
is it going to
link the list page?
JUSTIN BOYAN: Great question.
Both.
We recommend you do
both, if you can.
So the listing pages often are
higher ranked in search and
are going to get more views.
And so it's great if
the structured data
is available there.
For events in particular,
there is a rich snippet
treatment that will show
multiple events associated
with a single page up to, I
forget, three or four of them,
but will provide
separate links.
From the list page, it'll
actually provide multiple
links right off that snippet
into the details pages.
AUDIENCE: So if you're showing
something like let's say,
restaurants, I can show basic
restaurant data on the list
page in the structured markup.
Should I also show reviews in
that markup, or should I limit
that to let's say, the
detail page markup?
JUSTIN BOYAN: I honestly don't
know the answer to that.
I know for a details page that
markup will be featured.
And I'm not sure whether
multiple reviews on a listing
page would get a special
treatment in the rich snippet
for that listing page.
I'm not sure.
JOSH AIN: But there's the
picture of what happens right
now with Google and there's the
picture of what's going to
happen in six months.
I think that the more structured
data that we all
add to the web, the more we can
do with structured data.
And so we have motivations that
are current, and then the
more data that accumulates we
can add more motivations and
more uses of it.
AUDIENCE: Hi, my name
is [INAUDIBLE].
I'm working a large e-commerce
platform.
So I'd like to know, with this
structured data, if you add
some specific data like stock
and it's very dynamic, how
often is it queried or things
to show accurate data?
Is there any special treatment
for very dynamic data?
JUSTIN BOYAN: For very
dynamic data.
I think the Google crawl
is very dynamic.
So we are just responding to the
data as we see it in the
Google crawl, but the crawl
itself is very dynamic and
does a lot of self-adjusting
depending on the kind of site
and how often we detect that its
core content is updating.
So in that sense, it depends
on your site and the
properties of the crawl, but we
can't really influence that
much based on structured data.
AUDIENCE: On the website, is
there a plan to add this
structured data to products
like AdWords?
For the textiles, sometimes
it's very difficult to
generate a specific textile
for each group.
So it could be a good idea.
JUSTIN BOYAN: That is
a great idea for a
future Google product.
JOSH AIN: So you're saying to
generate ads based on the
structured data on your--
AUDIENCE: Yes, like a schema
textile, like a template and
filter is like an improvement
for a keyboard insertion.
JUSTIN BOYAN: I think it's a
wonderful idea to have that
sort of collaboration, but
there's no announcement of
anything like that planned,
as far as I know.
AUDIENCE: Thank you very much.
AUDIENCE: Are there plans to
add more data types or
potentially let users define
their own objects with the
data points, and then highlight
them and map them?
JUSTIN BOYAN: Yeah,
there aren't--
we haven't thought about letting
users extend that set
of types that are available to
tag, but there certainly are
plans for us to expand
that list.
We're basically growing this
product from scratch and
trying to get a sense of how
accurate the data is that
comes in through it.
And we're also careful not to
get too far ahead of ourselves
in exposing schemas
that Google isn't
making much use of yet.
So we don't want to make people
do a bunch of work--
AUDIENCE: How long has the Data
Highlighter been available?
This is the first I actually
had heard of it.
JUSTIN BOYAN: Yeah, it launched
in December, quietly
with a blog post on the
Webmaster Central blog.
And as of yesterday, it's
expanded just beyond events to
these eight data types.
It's also available
in 40 languages.
AUDIENCE: One last question.
What are some of the biggest
challenges that you still have
to solve for that potentially
Google or other
people could help with?
JUSTIN BOYAN: Biggest
challenges?
AUDIENCE: You mentioned that
it's not perfect, some pages
won't work.
Are there any specific things
that the community could help
with in any fashion?
JUSTIN BOYAN: Well, the Data
Highlighter tool, which is
machine learning based, there's
always going to be a
limit to what a pattern
recognition tool can do,
especially if your site is
excitingly variable.
So markup is always the safer
choice, where you can be very
specific and explicit about what
the data is on each and
every page regardless of
how it's formatted.
Nevertheless, we're always
working to improve the pattern
recognition so it does work
more smoothly on a higher
percentage of sites.
With Markup Helper there's a
challenge, because actually,
there are many ways to generate
the structured markup
for a given page.
And so we're continuing
to refine that.
This is an initial launch, but
we're looking at Ways to
simplify its output, always
generate the easiest, most
intuitive form of the markup.
So that's another focus.
JOSH AIN: The other piece that
I'd just add to your earlier
point, Data Highlighter was
launched in December.
Markup Helper launched today.
Structured Data Dashboard
launched last summer.
There's a lot of work
going on here.
We're trying to improve the
experience and we understand
that there's a lot of options.
We want to make it
easier for you.
So if you have pain points using
structured data that are
not being addressed,
come talk to us.
We'd love to learn about them.
JUSTIN BOYAN: Yeah, and we will
be, after lunch, at the
third floor Knowledge Sandbox.
And also, there is the Webmaster
Tools forum which is
open, and that's where we
monitor people's feedback on
these tools.
AUDIENCE: Sorry,
it's me again.
Is the structured data that you
put into the site, is that
going to be pulled into stuff
like Maps and some of the
other things that we're shown
with regards to Google+ and
stuff like that?
JUSTIN BOYAN: We are sensitive
about pulling data from
people's web pages out of the
context of those web pages,
because we realize we're
in an ecosystem.
But having said that, we are
always looking for the best
possible user experience.
So we want to do the best job
of both answering user's
questions and directing them to
the authoritative owners of
web content.
So yes.
JOSH AIN: I think G+
will definitely use
structured data in some--
sometimes the same vocabulary,
sometimes different
vocabularies, to preview
the content of
a page that's shared.
And otherwise, we're using
structured data now, or
planning to use it wherever it
make sense-- we have enough
coverage and we have the right
motivation with the webmaster.
AUDIENCE: I help manage a large
commerce site, so we
have a dot com and then a mobile
property, as well.
Mobile property is powered
by an API.
All the content data is the
same, but it's just a
different back end.
So we use structured data
on the big site.
On the mobile site, though, we
don't use structured data.
Is that a problem?
Should we be using structured
data for the mobile
property, as well?
JUSTIN BOYAN: Good question.
So you mean like a
mobile website?
You're not talking
about an app?
AUDIENCE: No, it's actually
m dot ticketmaster.com
JUSTIN BOYAN: M dot.
I don't know.
I'm going to answer that one
with an I don't know.
JOSH AIN: I think it depends
on your search strategy.
If you're referring to your
desktop version of your site
as canonical in all instances,
then you don't expect your
mobile site to show
up in search.
So for the motivations that we
were showing today, it doesn't
matter if it's on your
mobile site.
If you do expect the mobile
site to be a first order
destination, then it is useful
to have the same structured
markup that you're already
using on your main site.
AUDIENCE: OK, thanks.
AUDIENCE: Similar question.
If we already have structured
data in the form of JSON or
any sort of external API, is
there a simple way to just
link from our product page that
you're crawling to where
that structured data
already is?
JUSTIN BOYAN: No.
I don't think so.
You mean, if you have--
so your data is not in the web
page, but it's available on
the web in some other format?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I mean, most
web pages get created from
some sort of structured
data already.
So if we already have that--
in fact, we're creating our
web pages from a back end API
already, so why not just give
you a link to that instead
of peppering our
HTML page with it?
JUSTIN BOYAN: There is,
philosophically, to us a
benefit to having the markup
right in the user-visible web
page, because that's, to us,
the ultimate guarantee that
the structured data we're
showing corresponds to the
user-visible version
of that data.
And if you point us to the API
directly and explain the
mapping somehow that way, maybe
that's right for your
site, but in some other site the
two data sources might get
out of sync.
AUDIENCE: Well, the question
was actually--
I thought of it based on his
mobile question just
previously.
There are numerous ways to
consume the same data that
we're providing to our users.
And so creating that structured
data in every
format of consumption, whether
it's mobile or other third
party applications or web, it
all points back to that same
structured data in
the first place.
So putting out multiple copies
of all of the structured data
seems confusing, potentially,
for Google and others.
JUSTIN BOYAN: Well, it's just
some lightweight HTML
annotations on the
presentation.
And so if you're presenting in
multiple ways, I don't think
you should necessarily think of
it as a huge burden to put
those annotations on each
different presentation.
JOSH AIN: But I also think that
you're going to have a
canonical version, or you can
specify a canonical version.
And so the canonical version, I
believe, is what we're going
to refer to in search,
not the other
representations of the same page.
So if the structured data is
there in the canonical
version, then we'll
understand it.
I'd also add that, as we saw in
this little crying slide,
we do understand lots of
different formats.
But as Justin said, we prefer
to be on the page so that we
can actually associate it with
the user-visible data.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, to seem like
a single canonical
version for the web.
But then it seems like it would
be even better to have a
single canonical version for all
presentations of that same
information.
JUSTIN BOYAN: Let's talk
about this more.
JOSH AIN: Yeah, we'd love
to keep talking.
Looks like we're out of time.
But thank you all.